the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright let's get started today's topic
would be distributed algorithms we will
look at two new algorithms but they are
similar to what you have seen in the
lectures so it will also be a review of
some concept in lectures
so our first example would be again
leader election simple
the simplest example but this time the
network anthropology would be a ring so
in the lectures how the example we see
is a clique meaning they are fully
connected every node can talk to every
other node there if you remember our
solution is to for everyone to generate
a UID or random number and if you are
the maximum then you output you out
their leader it's you can do that
because yeah you are connected to
everybody so you immediately know what
random number everybody generates and
you can compare whether you are the
largest now the idea is the same if we
have a ring so you want everyone to
generate the ID or random number I'll
just say ID from now on and you want to
collect everyone else ID so that you
know whether your ID is the largest
among all of them okay
Oh
okay the question is where the
comparison happened so we first need
some way to pass the numbers around such
that everyone has everyone else's number
you have the number of everyone then you
can compare whether the largest equals
yours if the largest equals yours then
you know you are the largest and you're
going to output I'm the leader okay so
the difficulty is just how to pass the
numbers around so that everyone sees
everyone else's number any ideas simple
solution
well there's not much you can do you
just connect to your two neighbors a
loved one the right one
so how do you propagate an information
okay so what does broadcasting me here
okay
and just let me call them ABC yeah and
yes we can tell D or can tell P how does
C tell eat
yeah so it would be just say everyone
talks to it right neighbor and then P
has a side EC has be tidied you have
seized ID and then continue and toss
around next time so just to make it
perfectly say they generate some random
IDs that's 5 10 20 and then in the next
around a would send its ID to be B will
send its ID to see C would send its ID
to D and then the next around B would
pass this information along to see C
would pass the information to D and just
continue and eventually everyone will
have everyone else's ID so how many runs
do we need
if they are in notes in the system
I'm I think you can do it either way
will be if you propagate both ways
you've probably 2x faster yeah yeah
correct
it's just over then but to keep it
simple let's say we just propagate in
one direction that's also fine still all
of them so how many messages are sent in
toto
on it
and square yep is that obvious to
everyone
okay give an explanation
yeah yeah everyone everyone everyone
everyone sends a message or you can
think of every message a message is
propagated at end times and there are n
messages in total
okay yeah that's definitely your
solution well you can imagine it's
probably the naive solution and can we
do better than that
okay good question so if we if they know
there are any of them yet then they know
how to terminate so your question is how
to terminate right if they don't
eventually you will receive your own ID
on the other side if we keep sending
left eventually it was receive it on the
left report yeah that's a that's an
indication of termination
yeah we usually assume that yeah either
it's a unique user ID yeah sorry UID
what does you stand for by the way or if
you generate random numbers in a large
range it's very unlikely that they
collide
okay so can we do better than that
have some idea
mm-hmm okay I think you have two ideas
by the research we'll see how that works
later so you said only four words
something that's larger okay
yeah that's on the right track so one
obvious thing we can do is that so we
actually don't care what all the ideas
are right we only care whether a certain
idea is the largest so for example in
this case when a send its ID five to be
be knows this five won't be the leader
because five is too small it's even
smaller than his ID so we can choose to
drop this message there is no point in
passing that message further same thing
for this message message she knows that
10 is too small and it doesn't have to
pass it along
of the ID it's just the integer each
node chooses at random say yeah the only
purpose of the idea is to break symmetry
so yeah like we have seen in the lecture
if they don't do this if they don't have
any unique identifiers they won't be
able to select the leader and when they
have a unique number then they can
select yeah the largest one
smallest one or some in some way
okay that's this optimization make sense
we can cut drop several messages that
have no chance of becoming the leader
corrupting yep that's yeah very good
question and very good answer by the way
but how effective is this well in
average case you may we may be able to
drop some messages but there are
pathological case where it actually
doesn't help at all say this is the ID
we choose then when there's 20 its stand
around be cannot drop it because it it's
probably maybe the largest and when this
10 is sent to see you see cannot drop it
and when 20 comes along it also cannot
drop it it's only no node can drop any
message its worst case is still and
square
okay so let's think about the binary
search equivalent yeah how to binary
search in this case
yeah good question it's not very
probably obvious binary searching - what
yeah just some binary idea that that
will give us a log inbound so actually
that's the this is the better algorithm
but once you have a log in you can
probably guess okay go ahead yeah that's
not the right yeah
yeah that's definitely the right idea
okay let's detail it a little bit how do
you carry it up
dividers hit
okay
okay so then it's let them select their
leader respectively and compare which
one is larger it's interesting thought
I think the first difficulty I see is
that if you cut it by half it's no
longer a ring
yeah yeah correct yeah yeah
it's definitely not an easy problem
another another easy algorithm and the
idea is to well you had the right idea
that we want to what store it let the
weak candidates
shut up early so what I mean by that is
say we have several round that is B and
a and C we all let be only propagate to
ANC first if B is the local maximum
among ABC then P will try to talk
further increase its range if B is not
the local maximum of ABC then yeah it
can be quiet in doesn't need to send
messages anymore if B succeeds in the
next round then you go further increase
its range to try to talk to more people
okay so how does it work in detail well
so in round I we will let a note send
this message up to to raise to i hops in
this case it's one and in next round is
two and then four if at any point some
note like along this range decides that
you are not the local maximum then they
will reply that yeah you can you no
longer need to send messages anymore if
this message successfully reaches this
end point that you raised to IHOP's then
this guy will respond and this guy if it
still thinks you are the local maximum
then it will respond a message saying
yeah continue
and if the sender receives this
continuing message on both sides then it
will continue into the next round
otherwise it will go inactive
it's the algorithm clear
I say that again
oh okay in the first round everyone sent
their messages okay then some of them
will go inactive because they learn they
are not the maximum and the remaining
the surviving surviving ones well yeah
continue sending messages and then yeah
half of them probably will die in the
next round and the surviving ones keep
sending messages make sense
yep so we will send a message of this
form say well some message and then we
will send a hop and the direction either
left or right and this hop will
initially be set to 2 raise to I number
ground then when this guy receives the
message it will decrement the hop count
and pass it along and every note when
forwarding a message will decrease a dot
H by one and finally when it reaches
here that number becomes zero and when
you see when it when a note sees a
message with zero hop count it going
it's going to reverse it send it in the
other direction and again started back
to 2 raised to I
this message I should say ID and that at
certain point set a certain note may
decide this idea is too small it doesn't
have a chance then it can directly send
it in the opposite direction replying a
message saying yeah you are too small
okay so any more questions on algorithm
yourself if not what's the next step
yeah time complexity so I already
claimed it's n log n is it
this is round this is message this is
also a message complexity
and so why is it then again
so we have a certain number of rounds so
how many rounds do we have
yeah maybe but yeah I'll just say login
because yeah you're increasing your
hotline and we're going to compute like
how many nodes are still active in each
round how many messages are sent in that
round so well the number of nodes active
just will just be this number if we
start from zero why it's the first time
everyone is active in next time only one
third of them will be active but we said
we are conservative here and we put one
half right next round is actually one
fifth it's the local maximum if it's
local maximum it means like these two
and those two will go inactive but we
put this as a upper bound
so this is the number of notes that are
still active and they will send the
message up to this many hops
and there are two directions
and you send a message back and then
sorry send a message forward and someone
will reply but in the end this is a
login
yeah I think I got eight and log n so my
recitation notes s is full again
not entirely sure whether than what's
going on yeah but you can double check
whether this is correct or the
recitation note is correct
nice the number ground in the eighth
round yeah this many notes are still
active and each of them will send a
message this many hops
and I didn't mention whether this is
whether the network is synchronous or
asynchronous and it turns out it doesn't
care
its algorithm can work for both
synchronous and asynchronous apparently
it works for synchronous networks if
it's asynchronous then what changes is
that different nodes are in different
rounds or certain around me a certain
node may be far ahead than the others
but it's fine eventually they will
converge to the correct result okay so
let's look at the second problem problem
is it defined even simpler we just want
to count how many nodes are out there we
want the algorithm to work both
synchronously and asynchronously by that
I just mean we have a network
well say you have a lot of notes after
that just want to count how many nodes
are there in this network
so I'll give you say one minute to let's
first come up with a high-level plan
now it's the problem clear
mm-hmm okay I haven't defined that let's
not worry about complexity now for now
the complexity will depend on the number
of nodes n and the number of edges e
let's just get it functionally correct
can anyone share a high-level strategy
okay
IDs of the other places
it's clearly
on what edge yeah it wasn't in both on
both edges mm-hmm okay so then maybe
it's n the one here and send the 1 here
there then this node will think it has a
children it has a child right which is
this one let's just say this is this is
the entire network and what message does
it send to this guy
now you probably need sent to here
because you have one and this is
possibly its child right but then we're
double counting this note you see the
problem
oh yeah they have the Artie's oh okay
we're going to send all the IDs
okay yeah that's the interesting thought
and then still you may still need a root
that one have will have everyone's ID
and then see how many unique guys are
there okay interesting does this
algorithm work yeah I don't see any
problem
okay let me still repeat what our
algorithm is it's because it's closer to
what's in a lecture so we're going to
find a spanning tree of this network
spanning tree means well like I have to
cut one of these edges if I have a tree
but then I can have every child report
to its parent
how many offsprings including myself do
I have and this this node will sum up
always always children and report to its
parent
does everyone get that so first I'll
find a standing tree
and second we'll have child reports to
parents
good question so in a lecture we have
seen algorithm that find BFS spanning
tree for synchronous networks this is
review after lecture how does it work
mmm
each node will say we need to first
choose the route and our route will just
send a message to its neighbor and yeah
saying you are my child you imagine you
are my child you're my child and then
every note upon receiving this message
from the message from the parent will
search among its neighbors so the
neighbors that haven't got a parent will
acknowledge this sender as the parent
okay that's a little messy
so this note will search to the leaf
node but then it will also try to search
for this guy but this guy already has a
parent then yeah I was a I already got a
parent and blah blah blah
this will give us a BFS spanning tree
what does it mean it's a spanning tree
found by BFS does it work for a
synchronous Network
okay
yeah correct so why does this version
not work work for a synchronous network
yeah exactly so let me give a concrete
example
what does asynchronous network mean is
that well messages travel at different
speed say this link for some reason is
temporarily done and this node doesn't
receive the message from the route and
then this message travels very fast and
this message also travels very fast so
this message may reach this node earlier
and then this this node will think of it
as a child of this node okay and then
this message comes along finally but
this note says yeah I already have a
parent and I'm going to reject you yes
good point this is not a BFS spanning
tree but it's it's still a spanning tree
right so in our problem we were totally
fine with it yeah but you do have to
know if you really want a BFS spanning
tree in an asynchronous Network then you
have to like recall the distance and do
the relaxation and so on and so forth
okay so we will just use this algorithm
the BFS spanning tree algorithm just run
it asynchronously it doesn't find a BFS
spanning tree but it finds some finds
that some spanning tree
okay how does this algorithm work we
will have several variables
the first one is parent we will
initialize it to this undefined single
okay then every note will pass around
this search message mmm I use a slightly
more shorthand notation than from the
lecture
okay let's say the code I wrote is for
process you okay
if we receive a message a search message
from V to u that means you are sorry V
is trying to become our parent okay
and
if I do not have a parent yet I should
set the parent to be
okay so what's the next step
we got this search message from our
parents and we have to pass it along
oh yeah quick yeah we first need to
respond by saying okay oh you said well
show their notation send these a cue
that that's the message that will be
sent to me at some point well the
message we sent is parent one parent -
this is a response to be saying yeah you
are my parent okay then else we also
have to respond
by saying iron zero you are not my
parent because I already got some other
parent missing a stop here
if we receive a search message go ahead
yeah we need to pass it to all my
potential children so I use this gamma
you mean meaning the neighbors of you
Thanks
and then I'll send them a message what
message
such
okay
okay so well naturally since we created
a we have a search message and we know
how to deal with it now we are sending
this parent message with a better deal
with it right so then the next chunk of
code should be if we receive this parent
message I was a parent B meaning this
message come comes with either two of us
I received this message from some notes
W okay I'm still you here because I just
to send all the message to to all the WS
to all my neighbors and they should give
me a response
okay if B is 1 that means this
particular W take me as its parent make
sense so I'd better have a list of my
children I want to track that I want to
keep track of that how we will create a
new variable for children it's going to
be initialized to what yeah empty set
and now if this is one I'm going to put
that bill in this children list
okay I'm leaving some space here
because our root should be slightly
different so every other node will send
search messages when they'd received a
search message we need someone to
initiate make sense so if you equals
root we say the root is v-0
so two things should happen first we
should set its parent to some special
value say root
and then I should copy this blob blob of
code to here
right this is a little crowded but hope
is still legible
okay this is already uh almost a correct
algorithm except that we don't know how
to terminate if we wait long enough then
everyone will receive all the responses
and everyone will know its parent and
this child list but how do we terminate
yeah that's a that's one way to do it
after anyone's but the whole point is we
are trying to find what n is we don't
know how many nodes are there
oh yeah if you receive a response either
either parent zero or parent one from
all your neighbors then your job is
pretty much done but the others have not
right so you send the message very fast
they responded to you and they are still
working very hard okay so then we need
to use the technique from the lecture
that's called convergecast so everyone
will send a done signal when it is done
and all its children are also done okay
to do that I'm going to define a new
variable called searched searched means
someone has responded in this case W has
responded
I'll put it into the search the list no
matter whether it accepts me as parent
or reject okay then naturally I need to
define this variable here
as a last step if
they search the list because my neighbor
list that means everyone has responded
and all my children are done
then I need a new variable coat done
that's another list okay who has finish
and who has not
okay say this one search to means
someone has responded to the search
message okay
done means always children are done its
I haven't right what how done is defined
I'll give me a minute in this case I'm
going to send my parent a message this
is the step of convergecast what do I
send I'm going to send I'm done
okay then whenever we create a message
we should deal with that message if we
if we receive a message I'm done what do
we do from from W then we are going to
mark that note as done
okay this is there's a saddle point so
someone has to initiate the done signal
that's going to be our leaves why
because when this condition check they
don't have any children their children
list is empty set and they're done list
is also empty set but they're going to
send I'm done signal first and then all
the intermediate nodes will send the
done signal when all these children are
done okay so this is the convergecast
version only gives us a termination
point of the of our spanning tree search
we haven't count the number of nodes in
a network that's a small modification
we're just going to include that number
in the I'm done signal so then I'm I
need to define another variable called
total let's initialize to zero this
variable will track how many nodes do I
have in my subtree including me and all
my children then when I send that I'm
done signal I'm going I'm going to send
this sorry that's not right
when I'm sending the unban signal I'm
going to send my total number of
offspring with it and when I receive
someone my job might one of my children
reports that I do have T children I need
to increment my total by that amount
hmm okay I made a mistake again should
be total plus one right because I'm
counting all my children and then I
should include myself
so that's the company that wouldn't
yeah one purpose is just to create a
different angle to look at this VP the
algorithm you usually just tour that
Network graphs but sometimes it's
helpful to think about how the code
actually works okay that's all for today